Chúng thế gián gọi qua trước khi năm mới,
Flash Bóc bình bạn tết của Neslay đã thu hút yêu bạn chỉ khá hướng khả.
Sữa bắt người và hồi hôm chính là đều đẩu của chi khổ biệt ngại.
Được biết, Flash Bóc bình bạn tết của Neslay là một qua dân trong những người chơi máy mắn,
chính thăng cuộc thiên Flash Tét chất lợi trước quả chất chơi,
sôn Neslay Việt Nam đồng hành tổ chức.
Theo số liệu của đồng bị tổ chức của thiên cấp,
xong cuộc tháng chình thay,
chính trình lợi thu cuốn tháng chăm nghìn lưu thảo luật,
và hành hình bài chiếc sẻ khỏi khắc đó tết chỉ các tránh mạng sả hội.
Nen trong cuộc khổ chương trình,
con Neslay có phía trưa lợi chúng tai,
Flash Bóc bình bạn tết của Neslay,
khi cám nhiên một hạt động,
có mắn qua 9 mắn chỉ được cơ sản phẩm bất ngờ,
và trưa lợi ra trân vụ yêu dông,
đo trình bị kiếm lỗ chù đáo,
với xác sĩ trị trông, trên đi,
cùng vào yêu dông đón trường một khởi đồng mai mắn chơi năm mới.
Chương trình của Neslay có phía trưa lợi chúng tai
cho phía trình thành mắn xa đình bệnh.
Thông qua những món quả được đáo,
Neslay mong muốn tôn bình xa chỉ kết trên thống,
kết hợp tình tình tình tình tên trên lộ,
để năng để một mô tết và mạc và đại đu gân.